ehi tu proprio tu futuro friggitore di
patatine sei stanco di non riuscire a
scaricare il tuo film o la tua serie
preferita perché la tua connessione
arriva dritta dagli anni 80 e ti ci
vogliono sette anni per scaricare 30
mega byte sei stufo di vedere streaming
registrati dal cinema con un nokia 43 10
esiste la soluzione a tutto questo
piccolo inutile uomo netflix non sai
cos'è netflix con quella faccia lì non
mi stupisco netflix è un sito di
streaming online usufruibile tramite
abbonamento
lo so lo so che se si parla di
abbonamento l'italiano che c'è in te
inizia a stringere il culo ma stammi a
sentire due secondi per circa 8 dollari
al mese
si hai sentito bene 8 dollari al mese
che equivalgono a circa 6 euro
puoi avere accesso a centinaia di film e
serie tv e adesso mi ascolti vero
il catalogo è vastissimo possiamo
trovare pellicole di qualsiasi anno
regista e genere persino gay e lesbiche
no davvero c'è la categoria gay e
lesbiche fantastico ma non solo si
possono trovare una badilata di cartoni
animati anime spettacoli teatrali
programmi tv e wrestling
hai capito ignorantello da strapazzo
vuoi guardare i lost breaking bad fringe
dottor mura eccetera eccetera a 6 euro
al mese ma prima di iniziare a
masturbarti dalla felicità ascolta qui
non tutto è disponibile in streaming
ci sono alcune cose in dvd ora ti spiego
aggiungendo altri 8 dollari e portando
tutto a 12 euro puoi fare l'abbonamento
dvd dove puoi farti spedire a casa gli
ultimissimi film e serie tv spedire a
casa capisci il tuo culo non vedrà mai
più la luce del sole
lo sai che così come spotify per la
musica questo potrebbe sconfiggere la
pirateria paghi al mese quello che
pagheresti per un singolo cofanetto di
serie tv a e lo sai che netflix non è e
probabilmente non sarà mai disponibile
in italia a tassi mio giovane idiota
in italia non c'è perché ormai l'italia
in mano a singole multinazionali che
vogliono il controllo di tutto pure
della tua vita ma non temere c'è una
soluzione a tutto circa da poco in tv e
su internet ci stanno scartavetrato gli
zebedei con la pubblicità di questo
servizio ad abbonamento mensile come
netflix pieno di serie tv e film come
netflix tutto in streaming come netflix
ma totalmente italiano e frizzi
ho dovuto modificare il nome perché
probabilmente mi denuncerebbero
all'istante se dicessi quello vero che è
bella la libertà di pensiero in frizzi
costa 10 euro al mese e poi avere film
pochi ci sono quasi tutti quelli di totò
quasi tutti quelli di sordi quasi
nessuno di quelli di fantozzi il futuro
è quasi meglio che niente no anche su in
frizzi ci sono le serie tv come hannibal
berlin i pilastri della terra e queste
sono solo le tre famose possiamo trovare
anche a hamburg distretto 21 sante l
inter nato
sei contento
manco io affrettati che la sezione
fiction ti aspetta ti piacciono le
fiction di la verità ti si legge in
faccia che sei un appassionato ed
infatti c'è tutto quello che hai sempre
sognato
gabriel garko le tre rose di eva il
bello delle donne i segreti di borgo
larici e non sei una casalinga di
belluno
allora ti interesserà una delle poche
sedi passabili in italia distretto di
polizia
godi di tutte e due le serie come di ci
manca qualche puntata da c e paga
carogna c'è da dire che in frizzi è nato
da poco quindi è normale che non abbia
tutto ogni mese vengono aggiunti film e
serie nuove e questa è una bella cosa
vero ma o che cosa c'è qui la sezione
noleggio e ricordi che su netflix
pagando in tutto 12 euro potevi ricevere
i dvd a casa ecco qui puoi vedere in
streaming tutte le novità pagando tra i
2 e il 5 euro ma non al mese al singolo
film quindi se vuoi farti stuprare il
culo senza scontrino questa è la sezione
che fa per te affrettati e l'unica
alternativa a netflix come dici sei un
trentenne universitario se gli anni
fuori corso che vive con i genitori e
non ha i soldi manco per un bicchiere
d'acqua e ti sei rotto le palle di
youtube dove anche sotto i video di
auguri per le nonne accendo di questi
giorni c'è gente frustrata con problemi
mentali
abbiamo la soluzione anche per quello
cappio facile veloce e utili in ogni
occasione mancata della vita il vostro
sorriso è la nostra priorità
voi siete il futuro